what's that believe nation at seven my
one word is believe and I believe in
people more than they believe in
themselves and I want some of that to
rub off on to you so you can go off and
creat those amazing things that you've
got up in here bring them out to the
world so help you on your journey today
we're gonna look at the seven Habits of
self-made millionaires habit number
seven is I'm personal favorite and I'd
love to know which one you guys like the
best and as always as you're watching if
you hear something that really resonates
with you leave it down in the comments
below because when you write it down
it's much more likely to stick with
yourself as well as inspire other people
enjoy
I should mention one thing about reading
it was at the library here at Columbia I
wish I spent probably more time than any
other soon
I lived there practically but then I
pulled the book out there have to be
who's an American that told me something
about my professor Benjamin Ram and then
I looked up and a bunch of the library
and I said I want to learn more about
this because I learned this over here
that changed my whole life
you know we owned I go now because of
that librarian directing me to some
other book and then following through on
that now it's the chance I I read about
one-fifth the pace the bill does but I
still spend five or six hours a day
reading I mean it just you can learn so
much I particularly love biography just
you know to be able to live the lives of
these people have been extorted you can
see them so extraordinary in the lessons
and those you know the discouragements
they face just everything about it so I
just you can't get enough of reading
I have to show up and work with the
right attitude and with the positive
energy and I actually had a teacher made
this positive energy is a part of your
job description right so the the idea
that I want to show up with the right
energy I want to show up you know we're
out here you know even now we're all
here we're trying to feed our families
where we're trying to have a good time
we're trying out there this is important
our lives our time is all that we have
so to me it's really important to
deliver positive energy in a way because
it's like so and I come to positive
energy that someone else is going to
take all the positive energy and to take
it home to your families and you know so
for me it's just hugely important to
approach everything and everybody at
every turn with the the the most
positive love
that I can generate
I get up at crazy hours whether it's
three o'clock in the morning by the way
when we were talking in London I was
getting up at 3:00 because I had to be
on set by 4:00 I'm sorry by 7:00 so
whatever time my call time is and I tell
this to studios and directors and our
producers whatever told my call time so
my call time is at 7:00 then you back
your clock up for hours and then that's
when I get up and train twice I'll get
my cardio in and breakfast and I'll go
hit the weights clanging and banging we
call it Jack and the iron but like what
time do you go to bed I mean you might
shoot really late at night I'm averaging
on a movie on average probably about
five hours of sleep
do you remember the audition when you
first met an arrow that was yeah I mean
that was one of those incredible
auditions that came around that I
suppose every kid had been waiting for
for a long period of time because it's
just not that often that you get a
starring role above Robert De Niro in
this incredible you know screenplay and
was you know Ellen Barkin and Michael
Keaton Jones and was just everyone was
sort of feeding for this role and I got
done I suppose to the final five and
there's like a last sort of day
Toby was there and I I do remember
thinking to myself I got to do something
I got to do something to stand out and
in the audition there was art lence and
Michael Keaton Jones art lessons that
was a producer and DeNiro
and I remember there was a mustard jar
scene and he had to jam a mustard jar in
my eye repeatedly it was an abuse scene
and the script so didn't call for it but
I got up and I he said now is it empty
is it empty and I got up and I screamed
Oh like completely unnecessary but I
screamed in his face and I start there
you know with my head you know looking
like a red tomato and and and everyone
started laughing at me and then the
entire room de niro everybody was in
hysterics i sat there frozen's thinking
oh my god I just screwed this entire
and I just sat there frozen and then you
know Bob and traditional dinero
fashioned kind of just look to me when
it's good and and then you know we
carried on doing the scene and I think I
actually had dinner with De Niro
recently and he told me no I was the one
who said I was the one who said you
should get the get the job
what did you get that that business
sense because you you surpassed
everybody in in boxing and sports and
everything in general I'm watching you
it's like you bigger than a NFL
franchise
it's just mighty me believe it you know
I'm gonna be honest me and a lot of my
guys a lot of my said I have a team also
but you know my team don't get in there
and go to war like I go to war but they
go to war on the outside right then go
to war
I'm very very tough on my team
I want my team to be the best that they
can be on the outside and but as far as
on the outside you know al Heyman that's
all jela SOG a legend a legend a very
shrewd businessman Linda Ellerbee
and that master degree yeah you know in
business so you know when you surround
yourself with people like this just just
being around certain end of those
certain individuals like even been
around Don King been around Bob Arum
been around just different people that's
been in the game a long time and you
know my being there buddies you know
every time I got around my being there
buddies I was more like it's cool to
come over your house but I need a house
like this yeah it's cool to ride on your
yacht but I need to got like this is
cool around on your jet but I want a jet
like pensions and I said no I don't want
to ride on yours you showed me how to
get it you can't be my friend if you
can't show me how to get it because if
once they showed me how to get it in I
can install it in my children then it
goes it goes it drives down some
bloodline class so it's about wealth you
know I'm no longer rich I'm welcome
we've had this tradition for I don't
know probably seven or eight years at
the company where every week we have a
QA where where our employees can come
and ask me any question that they want
about what's going on and what the what
the direction of the company is or
questions or things that they read about
in the press or that their friends who
use the product what what they're asking
them and um and it's been this really
important tradition for us both because
we really believe in an openness and
communication and that's kind of what
Facebook is all about but it's also
really important for for me and for
running the company to be able to get
feedback right and and to be able to
learn what's on people's minds what our
what our employees and folks who were
who were part of our team are thinking
about and and just kind of a lot of the
time there are good questions that
people ask that changed the way that we
that we think about what we're building
and what we're here to do in the world
and that often make us go think and
reevaluate how we should be approaching
different problems
it's hard changing your life it was hard
when just over three years ago in the
Penobscot building in Detroit Michigan
where I was operating my business and I
fell on some hard times and I was
sleeping in my office
it was hard coming into the lobby and
the security said scuse me mr. Brown can
we see you for a moment and I said yes
and I walked up to the counter and he
gave me an envelope and he said would
you mind reading it here and I opened
the envelope and the envelope was from
management that says this is an office
tower it's not a hotel please do not
sleep in your office and I said excuse
me sir I said I just worked long hours
and creating my business I'm an
entrepreneur and right now things are
bad for me but they're not going to be
this way always and I just asked for the
opportunity to continue to operate like
I'm doing I'm not trying to make this my
home and it was hard coming through the
lobby and sometimes they would laugh
there's a guy talking about becoming
successful and look at him he's bathing
in the bathroom upstairs on the 21st
floor he sleeps on the floor him and two
other dreamers up there look at him
it was hard ladies and gentlemen coming
to speak to people and I was facing
financial difficulties in my own life I
was behind on my bills and my dreams and
I'm saying to them you can live your
dream it was hard ladies and gentlemen
it was very difficult to pick myself up
each day believing that I can do it
there were times that I doubted myself I
said God why why is this happening to me
I'm just trying to take care of my
children and my mother I'm not trying to
steal a Rob from anybody how did this
have to happen to me it was very hard
and here's what I want to say to you for
those of you that have experienced some
hardships
don't give up on your dream no one could
have convinced me by holding on by
continuing to push forward by continuing
to run toward my dream that one day I
would have my own talk show it's a long
shot ladies and gentlemen from Liberty
City an abandoned building order floor
never annoying my mother or father it's
a long shot
being here with you today in this dome
in Atlanta it's a long shot no college
training labeled educable mentally
[ __ ] but I kept running toward my
dream
goes down
dogs down
[Applause]
don't stop running to watch your dream
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I'd love to know what
did you think of this video rule number
seven was my favorite but which one was
yours leave it down in the comments also
did we miss an 8 9 and 10 that you wanna
add to the list let me know leave it
down the comments thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much love
I'll see you soon